اطلقهما مسلحون روس ينتمون لما يسمى بفيلق
روسيا الحره وفيلق المتطوعين الروس
الجماعتان الروسيتان المدعومتان من كييف
كثافه من ظهورهما مؤخرا وبعد كل هجوم
يستهدف روسيا المشاهد الجديده تاتي بعد
يومين من استهداف موسكو دون ان يعرف زمان
ومكان تسجيلها
المجموعتان تقولان انهما ستنفذان هجمات
جديده داخل الاراضي الروسيه
هدفهما وفقا لتصريحات افرادها هو تحرير
روسيا من حكم بوتين يقول مسلح فيلق روسيا
الحره انهم لن يتوقفوا حتى ترفع رايتهم في
سماء العاصمه موسكو في المشاهد الجديده
يؤكد المسلحون انهم لن يستهدفوا المدنيين
ابقوا في منازلكم ولا تقلقوا مقاتله
الفيلق الروسي لا يقاتلون ضد المدنيين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات